pounds ago breasts - and welcome to I
got a haircut I know I don't need a
million comments about it let's just
move on so spring is coming
which means winter is coming which means
shitty dark boring days are coming so I
wanted to make a video that will help
you bros learn how to smile a little
more and whenever I want to learn
something I go to the most factual
website on the Internet
tumblr little reasons to smile cute me v
[Music]
perfect paintings
finding a comfortable sleeping position
Harry Styles boys 18 patrolling kinda
catch me ridin dirty what are you doing
I'm busy try to catch me ridin dirty
tryna catch me ridin dirty
try to catch me running making cute
kissy faces feeling like your hair is
perfect
[Music]
ah
when guys do something that turns you on
[Music]
the sound of a perfect high five foot
petals I don't get it sulfur swells
around your bath though I don't have it
red you think I'm a loser
[Music]
this is not fair I will help you you're
free fly low burn I breath hope you
enjoyed this episode hope it made you
smile a little more
I saw you giggling up there a little bit
oh don't admit it
sorry maybe like if you enjoyed watching
I'll see you in the next episode Oh
forever I'm a thousand
[Music]